[Musique]
aujourd'hui je pense pouvoir sentir
entre 12 et 15 ministres ce qui
correspond à peu près à 125 mille cent
cinquante mille 12 qui fatalement
individuel ça veut dire que ce soir cent
cinquante mille personnes en france
auront un gel hydroalcoolique dans la
poche qui viendra plus ou moins ici
non
une solution hydroalcoolique
c'est la formule de l' oms de fabrique
le labo centralisée delpech ça nous
dépanne bien parce que moi même j'ai
commencé en fabriquer à la pharmacie et
les matières premières étaient
manquantes très rapidement
ça nous ça nous aide bien ils ont bien
du courage de fabriquer pour toute la
france
ça nous a bien dépanné le temps de
retrouver les stocks en gel
hydroalcoolique manufacture est parlé
par les fabricants un besoin énorme pour
les infirmières les maisons de retraite
m
[Musique]
les pharmacies des hôpitaux les pompiers
et la police lors ce genre en général
mais aussi des boulangers de boucher
tous ceux qui continuent de travail et
ont besoin d'avoir un solution hydro
alcoolique dans la poche on peut venir
ici
[Musique]